on a déjà vu de nombreux monstres des
mathématiques dans cette série sur
l'infini les séries divergentes aux
courbes remplissant en passant par
l'effraction continue les infinitésimaux
et l'analyse de fourier mais il en reste
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
donc plutôt que faire un épisode pour
chaque monstre des mathématiques
je me la jouer façon un petit peu
youtube et faire un top 8 des pires
monstres des mathématiques
la trompette de qu'abriel prenez
l'hyperbole l'équation y également sur x
et fait la tournée autour de l'axé des
abscisses n'obtient une espèce de trompe
est infinie c'est la trompette de
gabriel imaginée au xviiie siècle par un
certain torricelli un mathématicien avec
une moustache de champion dont on a déjà
parlé dans l'épisode 7
alors pourquoi est ce que cette
trompette est un monstre et bien c'est
parce que la surface à l'instar de la
trompette est infinie mais le volume à
l'intérieur de la trompette est bel et
bien fini il vaut même taux divisé par 2
qui est à peu près 3 14
mais du coup est ce que l'on peut
peindre l'intérieur de la trompette avec
une quantité finie de peinture d'un côté
on a envie de répondre que clairement
non puisque la surface à colorier est
infinie mais d'un autre côté ce que l'on
peut faire c'est verser le pot de
peinture à l'intérieur de la trompette
jusqu'à remplir la trompette avec une
quantité finie de peinture et à ce
moment là toute la surface intérieure
aura été colorée
la diagonale biscornu prenez un carré et
tracer la diagonale si le carré un côté
égal à 1 alors la diagonale l'hypoténuse
un triangle rectangle dont les côtés
adjacents sont de longueur 1
d'après le théorème de pythagore le
carré de la diagonale est donc la somme
des carrés des côtés opposés soit un
quart est plus un carré qui est égal à 2
du coup la diagonale à une longueur
égale à la racine carrée de 2 et si vous
tapez ça dans votre calculatrice vous
devriez trouver quelque chose comme mais
voilà ce qui est bizarre
prenez les deux autres côté du carré et
casser les vous obtenez insectes ont
brisé qui se rapproche de la diagonale
mais dont la longueur est la même
qu'avant à savoir de briser à nouveau le
scellement puis encore et encore et
encore
chaque fois que vous brisez le segment
vous ne modifiez pas sa longueur puisque
vous remplacer des bouts de côté par des
côtés de même longueur mais à l'infini
vous voyez que le segment brisé va
tendre vers la droite et du coup on a
envie de dire que la racine carrée de
2,2
le décollage sans secousse
prenez une fonction égale à zéro à
gauche
elle est alors parfaitement plate et on
pourrait penser qu'elle ne peut être
prolongé à droite que par la fonction
nul à présent dans son excellente vidéo
sur l'hypothèse de riemann madghis
longtemps que la seule bonne façon de
plonger de droite elle de la prolonger
en une droite mais non on peut définir
la fonction à droite comme étant égale à
e puissance moins un sur x les plus
habiles parmi vous pourront vérifier que
toutes les dérives et sont bien définis
pour x positif et quel temps de tout
vers zéro quand x tend vers zéro
autrement dit le raccordement en 0 se
fait de manière parfaitement lisse sans
aucune brisure ni secousses ce
prolongement dit c'est infini mais non
analytique a permis à cauchy de prouver
que de nombreux théorèmes de ses
prédécesseurs
la discontinuité uniquement rationnelle
dessiner une courbe mais pas forcément
une courbe lice mettez-y des
discontinuités priori on a envie de dire
qu'il n'ya qu'un nombre fini de
discontinuité ou du moins que ces
discontinuité sont assez rares et pas
partout eh bien non considérer la
fonction qui est égal à zéro pour tous
les nombres irrational et pour un nombre
rationnelle de la forme paix sûre qu en
fractions irréductibles on va lui donner
la valeur 1 sur q et bien cette fonction
va être continuant tout lé nombre
irrationnel mais 10 continue pour tous
les nombres rationnelle intuitivement
c'est parce que si on zoome suffisamment
près de tout point les seuls rationnelle
qui reste autour de ce point sont des
rationnel avec de très très grand
dénominateur et la fonction sera donc
quasiment nul
autour de ce point si je prends en
question est un irrationnel
la fonction il sera nulle et sera donc à
peu près égales en le point rationnelle
à sa valeur en tout point au tour mais
si le pont aux questions maintenant
rationnelle la fonction il sera
nettement plus grande en ce pont
rationnel que dans un voisinage très
petit
la courbe de weier strass
on a parlé des séries de fouiller dans
l'épisode 9
on a déjà vu que ces sommes infinie de
sinus et de cosigner je pouvais être
très très étrange
en 1870 karl valeur traces dont on a
déjà parlé dans l'épisode 7 découvrir
une série de fourier particulièrement
étrange cette série de fourier est
composé de cosinus de très très hautes
fréquences
et quand on ajoute plein de cosinus de
tra traders à haute fréquence
on va obtenir quelque chose qui est
intuitive mans va beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup aussi
mais un dessin vaut mille mots je ne
suis pas sûr que les mathématiciens de
l'époque était capable de visualiser
cette horreur mathématiques mais valeur
strass avait su démontrer que cette
courbe est parfaite ce nom continue
partout mais qu'elle n'est dérive abl
nulle part autrement dit elle n'a pas de
tendance ne peut pas dire si ça va
monter ou descendre parce que ça ne va
ni monter ni descendre ça va faire les
deux à la fois peu importe à quel point
on zoome
l'escalier de kantor magie une fonction
qui est continu c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
dessiner sans lever le crayon est tel
que ans quasiment tous points que l'on
dessine elle va être constante n'ont
envie de dire que la fonction va être
forcément du coup constante partout et
bien non l'un des pires monstres des
mathématiques est une fonction continue
qu'il va être constante presque partout
mais qui va aussi monter tranquillement
2 0 à 1
c'est ce que l'on appelle l'escalier de
kantor l'idée de la construction est la
suivante on commence par une diagonale
puis on introduit un plateau au milieu
du segment de longueur un tiers et ont
rejoint les bourgs ligne droite puis on
recommence à chaque montée régulière et
ainsi de suite l'objet que l'on obtient
à l'infini l escalier de kantor pour
comprendre l'escalier de kantor il est
utile de raisonner en base 3 basse roya
que trois chiffres 0 1 et 2 on voit que
la première étape de construction de
l'escalier de kantor consiste à isoler
les nombres qu'ils commencent par 0,1 ce
sont ceux qui sont au milieu puis à la
deuxième étape de construction de
l'escalier de kantor les points qui vont
devenir des marches des plateaux sont
les points qui commence par 0,01 et par
0,2 un et vous pouvez imaginer qu'elle a
énième étape de construction on va
rajouter des points dont la énième
décimales est égal à 1
du coup on voit qu'un point x criant
vaste roi va être un plateau de
l'escalier de kantor si et seulement si
il y à 1 1 dans son écriture en basse 3
or essayez d'imaginer comment on obtient
un nombre aléatoire entre 0 et 1
une façon de faire c'est de tirer
chacune de ces décimale de façon
parfaitement aléatoire et à ce moment là
la probabilité 2-1 1 dès la première
décimale va être égale à un tiers en
particulier la probabilité de ne pas
tirer de 1 à la première décimale va
être deux tiers mais du coup la
probabilité de ne tirer aucun parmi les
haines premières décimales veut être
égal 1 deux tiers pour la première
décimale fois deux tiers pour deuxième
décimale
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à la énième
décimales ce qui correspond à une
probabilité de 2/3 puissance n est du
coup la probabilité de tirer un nombre
qui ne contient aucun 1 va être plus
petit que tous les deux tiers à la
puissance elle pour tout n est le seul
nombre qui est plus petite hutte où les
deux tiers à la puissance n c zéro et du
coup la probabilité de tir un nombre qui
n'a aucun danser décimales est égal à
zéro
autrement dit la probabilité de tirer un
nombre qui a au moins 1 1 dans ces dsi
mal et qui du coup va forcément être un
plateau de l'escalier de kantor est égal
à 1
et c'est en ce sens que l'escalier de
kantor et plats presque partout
le tapis de cire pinsky prenez un tapis
car et découper leurs dents quadrillage
trois par trois et supprimer le carré du
milieu puis redécouper chacun des autres
carrés en un quadrillage 3 par 3
supprimer à nouveau l'écart et du milieu
et continuer ainsi à l'infini
il ne reste presque plus rien à l'infini
mais il reste un peu plus que rien il
reste au moins le contour du grand carré
mais aussi le contour des petits carrés
et ainsi de suite ce qui leur reste
c'est ce que l'on appelle le tapis de
cire pinsky on voit que le tapis de
sirkin ce qui est bien plus vite qu'un
carré mais il aussi bien plus plaint
qu'un segment de droite
or le carré a une dimension égale à 2 et
le segment de droite a une dimension
égal à 1
du coup on envie de dire que le tapis de
sierpinski une dimension qui est entre 1
et 2
et en effet il a une dimension fractales
entre 1 et 2 sa dimension fractales et
très précisément log de 8 / log de troie
qui fait à peu près 1,89
les punchs de menger on peut généraliser
le tapis de cirque pinsky en une épouse
de cire pinsky l'idée c'est de répéter
sous sa dimension 3 on part donc ce
n'est qu'une et on va enlever le cube
central
et puis ensuite pour chacun des succubes
qui composent le cube on enlève leur
cube centraux et ainsi de suite à
l'infini le seul problème avec cette
construction c'est que c'est pas
forcément très visuel puisque tout se
passe à l'intérieur du cube et nous
depuis les serres du cube tout ce qu'on
voit c'est un cube pour obtenir une
éponge plus jolie mais guère l'idée
d'enlever non seulement le cube central
mais aussi les cubes au milieu des faces
n'enlève alors sept des 27 cubes puis on
recommence avec les cubes qui restent à
l'infini on obtient les punchs de menger
comme vous l'imaginez peut-être cette
étrange éponge à une dimension fractales
elle aussi égal à loeb de 20 / log de 3
ce qui fait à peu près 2,73
j'espère que vous avez aimé ce topic
j'aimerais vraiment insisté sur le fait
que les monstres mathématiques que je
vous ai présenté aujourd'hui dans cette
vidéo sont littéralement des monstres
qui ont hanté les mathématiciens
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle et c'est
pour fuir de tels monstres mathématiques
que les mathématiciens ont inventé ou
réinventer la rigueur mathématique ce
truc qui vous fait vraiment ch et a les
cheveux
la rigueur ce n'est donc absolument pas
pour faire peur la rigueur est là pour
lutter contre la peur des monstres
mathématiques
d'une certaine manière la rigueur a
permis aux mathématiciens de se
construire des espèces de tour d'yvois
auquel les monstres mathématiques
n'avaient pas accès mais un monstre ce
n'est pas forcément si méchant il aura
fallu attendre les années 1960 pour
qu'un mathématicien du nom de benoît
mandelbrot et réussissent enfin à
apprivoiser ces monstres des
mathématiques et même à les transformer
en des princes des mathématiques
depuis les fractales demande de brut ont
trouvé une quantité faramineuse
d'application de l'étude biologique des
alvéoles pulmonaires au film d'animation
assistée par ordinateur en passant par
les structures à grande échelle du
cosmos et le design des antennes de
télécommunication la dernière fois on a
parlé des courbes qui remplissent
l'espace et vous avez eu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de questions du coup
je veux m'excuser parce que je vais pas
avoir le temps de traiter toutes vos
questions liées aux pros demande
pourquoi il ne suffirait pas de faire
des exergue pour colorier le carré bien
si vous faites un gig puis un zinc
question est ce que vous mettez de
l'espace entre l'audi et les ags est ce
que si vous mettez aucun espace entre le
zig zag le zag va être égal aux ig est
en fait vous n'avez jamais décollé mais
si vous mettez un tout petit espace
entre les zigs et des zags et bien vous
allez décoller mais du coup va avoir un
trou entre le zig et zag
alors bien sûr avec des vrais crayon en
pratique l'épaisseur du crayon fait
qu'encore est en fait plus un rectangle
qu'une droite mathématiques mais là dans
le cas des courbures remplissant deux
épisodes précédente
on veut vraiment s'intéresser à la
courbe mathématiques c'est à dire qu'on
peut colorer qu'un point à la fois et en
particulier le trait de crayon n'a
aucune épaisseur et à ce moment là si le
zag et au dessus du zik
il y aura forcément un espace
les eagles a donc le zig et zag ça
marche pas le sinus insurgés x non plus
ne marche pas c'est un peu plus tricky
et c'est un exemple assez amusant si
vous dessinez ça sur budget par exemple
vous obtenez une courbe qui a l'air de
remplir l'espace localement et c'est
vrai que si vous prenez un point qui est
sur l'axé des ordonnées que vous
regardez légèrement à droite il y aura
toujours une infinité de points qui
seront colorier dit que l'axé des
ordonnées en tout cas entre 0 et 1
est ce qu'on appelle une valeur
d'adhérence de la courbe
dès que vous vous éloignez de likes
désordonnée vous vous retrouvez un point
où il ya un espèce de zigs et des zags
c'est d'ailleurs une distance minimale
qui sépare le point légèrement à côté de
la désordonnée de la première fois
qu'ils vous qu'un autre point à côté va
être connus hydroxy chloride nous fait
aussi la remarque que le fait que l'on
puisse enlever le premier chiffre donne
notre adresse du point qui est très liée
à la première est en fait il ya des
similarités d'échelle donc c'est
vraiment le concept d'auto signori t qui
est au coeur du concept de fractal dont
un petit peu aussi parlé dans cet
épisode et ça répond à la question de
flou vaines
oui les cours de piano et de liberté
sont des fracas les ont des propriétés
d'auto similarités mais la dimension de
ces fractale elle est pas vraiment
fatale puisqu'elle est égal à 2 et ça
c'est en surprend plus d'un parmi vous
notamment ludovic b et professeurs
culture précieuse qui font la remarque
que si on déplie le collège moderne
obtient un segment 0 1 qui lui est de
dimension 1 du coup est ce que ça veut
dire que le carré et de dimensions est
lui aussi bien la réponse est
non le careï bien deux dimensions 2 et
le segment bien deux dimensions 1
en fait le fait que l'on puisse colorier
avec un objet de dimensions 1 de façon
continue en objet de dimension deux ne
veut pas dire que les deux objets ont la
même dimension ou autrement dit les
fonctions continue ne préserve pas la
notion de dimension et en particulier la
définition que nous donne parfois encore
de physique en disant que la dimension
c'est le nombre de degrés de liberté où
nombre de variables qu'il faut pour
préciser la position d'un point sas à
définir sur la elle fausse est
contredite par la courbe des îles berthe
est à cours de piano il la bonne
définition du concept de dimension est
une définition très difficile à
comprendre qu'ils utilisent des notions
topologique notion d' ouvert je vais pas
pouvoir vous donner la définition de ce
qu'est la dimension ici dans cette vidéo
mais sachez que le premier a prouvé que
le plan et la droite où effectivement
des dimensions différentes et un certain
henri poincaré il a prouvé sa avec des
outils très sophistiqué de topologie
algébrique dont j'ai un petit peu parlé
dans cet épisode ce que je trouve
intéressant à tirer de tout ça c'est que
poincaré a prouvé tout ça après les
travaux de liberté et de paix à nos et
ça ça devrait vous montrer que la notion
de dimension que l'on croit comprendre
intuitivement est en fait loin d'être
facile à comprendre
julien lauriane burger et dj matt 25 ont
bien vu que la construction du temps tu
es où on va colorier un point donné et
mal défini si on considère le point qui
est au centre du carré en fait c'est mal
définition considère n'importe quel
point qui est sûr l'une des séparations
du quadrillage que l'on pourrait faire
depuis en scène par deux puissants celle
du carré puisque si on prend un point kg
et sur l'une des droites du kayak et
appartient en fait à deux carrés à la
fois et bien il appartient donc à la
fois ça veut dire que l'on peut
construire deux instant t comprenant le
carré en haut ou en bas que l'on veut on
va donc pouvoir construire deux instants
voire plus sain pour le point central on
va pouvoir construire trois instants
différents et à chacun de ces instants
on va colorier ce point en question
autrement dit les points qui sont au
niveau des quadrillages ce sont les
points dont l'une des coordonnées terne
10 adriq c'est-à-dire nombre qui est un
nombre entier / une puissance de 2 la
plupart de ces nombreux la pac tous mais
la quasi-totalité de ses nombreux la
sent donc qu'en fait colorier plusieurs
fois par le motif de hubert tison qui
n'ont pas une budget ctions mais une
surge hexion du carré par le segment
zéro
valentin drop et marjorie reyes font la
remarque que en fait le coloriage à
l'infini vannes vitesse infinie et en
effet ça c'est intimement liée aussi à
la notion de dérivés la courbe de piano
et la courbe de liberté ne sont des
rivales nulle part et c'est en partie
parce que la vitesse qui serait la
dérive et est infinie donc si on regarde
la vitesse un instant donné
vitesse et justin fini mais si on
regarde la vitesse moyenne entre deux
temps donné cette vitesse moyenne est
toujours fini vous invite à réfléchir à
ce que je viens dire la vitesse moyenne
entre deux instants données est toujours
fini ma vitesse instantanée et toujours
pas défini tueur infinie fait dans
toutes les directions quasiment en même
temps en particulier ça ne contredit pas
le fait que le coloriage et bien sans
lever le crillon il faut colorier vite
quand même avoir un sacré coup de poêle
et enfin flotte au rwanda chaillet
demande s'il est possible de colorer un
espace de dimension rafini bérenger
seguin fait on remarque que si l'espace
de dimension infinie d'un espace de
dimension indénombrables mans infini
alors c'est morte ça c'est très bien vu
et il rajoute que si on veut un
coloriage qui est continu il faut
absolument que l'image d'un compact d'un
compact ça c'est un théorème que
d'ailleurs je trouvais dans une vidéo au
quotidien
or il y a des hypercube de dimension
infinie qui ne sont pas compact c'est
dire que en gros ils sont
vraiment pas fini et du coup par exemple
si on regarde hypercube de l'ensemble
des suites avec la topologie norm norme
de boutons infinie et bien sachant que
les hypercube de ces espaces là ne sont
pas compact c'est mort
après il ya des normes pour lesquels
l'hyper cube est un ensemble contact ce
qui est possible de les colorier
j'avais dit que j'allais y réfléchir a
fait pas assez réfléchi mais du coup je
vais sortir la réponse classique du
professeur qui c'est pas ben je vous
laisse en exercice et j'espère que vous
avez aimé cet épisode la prochaine fois
on va montrer que les nombres
rationnelle sont à la fois partout et
nulle et en mathématiques
c'est possible si vous avez aimé cet
épisode france est laïque et à le
commenter à le partager pensez à vous
abonner pour pas manquer les futurs
épisodes merci au type heures pour
landon et j'espère que vous verrez comme
la courbe de bangkok les côtes
britanniques n'étaient pas une figure de
dimension à n'étaient pas filmés et
n'était pas non plus une surface mais
une dimension intermédiaire il a trouvé
assez de culot dimensions égales à 1,20
de marina bay